Professeur Christine Hayes: Je parlais dernier
fois sur le concept d'élection ou de choix,
Le choix de Dieu d'Israël, Israël comme l'élu,
qui se produit pour la première fois dans le livre du Deutéronome.
Et je parlais du fait que, pour le Deutéronome
élection d'Israël, l'élection d'Israël par Dieu signifie
ou implique l'idée qu'Israël est un peuple saint,
saint dans le sens de la séparation de Dieu - que la signification profonde de
sainteté qui signifie d'être séparé de la commune ou l'
ordinaire. Alors que la séparation entraîne
séparation des peuples et des pratiques exotiques qui sont
incompatible avec le culte de Dieu.
Donc, pour cette raison, les mariages mixtes avec la
Cananéens est interdit dans le Deutéronome.
Et, en fait, ils doivent être totalement
détruit. Toutes les pratiques étrangères doivent être
retirée de la communauté de l'alliance.
Maintenant, étant donné qu'il n'y avait probablement aucun Cananéens à l'
le temps de la composition du Deutéronome,
selon certains chercheurs, ces textes peuvent être comprises
comme une sorte de polémique interne par rapport à ces éléments d'
La société israélite dont les pratiques ne sont pas conformes aux
Yahvé seule politique du Deutéronome,
ou Yahweh-seuls idéaux.
C'est une idée que nous y reviendrons dans un instant.
Je veux juste jeter ici.
La séparation implique aussi une séparation au service de Dieu.
Cela signifie, bien sûr, le respect de ses lois,
en particulier les lois de pureté, le rejet du païen
pratiques, et ainsi de suite.
Ainsi, le privilège d'avoir été choisi ou distingué,
d'être un peuple saint à Dieu entraîne des obligations et
responsabilité. Dans le même temps,
il est intéressant que le Deutéronome semble être au courant de
quelques-uns des dangers de cette idée,
le danger d'un complexe de supériorité, un danger moral impliqué
dans la notion d'élection.
Alors Deutéronome avertit à plusieurs reprises: il n'est pas spécial
la vertu ou le mérite qu'Israël était l'élu.
Et Moïse avertit les Israélites de ne pas supposer que
leur héritage de la terre de Canaan est due à leur propre
pouvoirs, ou en raison d'une
la justice et de la vertu qu'ils possèdent.
En fait, dit-il, loin de là.
Israël a été choisi par Yahvé dans un acte d'amour spontané -, il
n'implique pas la perfection - un acte de
amour spontané pour les patriarches.
Et l'élection était entièrement l'initiative de Dieu et pas de cause
pour Israël de se vanter.
Alors Deutéronome 7, versets 6-8 lire:
Car tu es un peuple consacré [sanctifié]
à l'Éternel, votre Dieu de tous les peuples de la terre l'
Seigneur votre Dieu vous a choisi pour être son peuple précieux.
Ce n'est pas parce que vous êtes les plus nombreux des peuples qui
le Seigneur jette son dévolu sur vous et vous a choisis -;
en effet, vous êtes le plus petit des peuples;
mais c'était parce que le Seigneur vous a favorisé et maintenu le serment qu'il
fait à vos pères que le Seigneur vous a libéré d'un puissant
main et vous a sauvé de la maison de servitude,
du pouvoir de Pharaon, roi d'Egypte.
Donc, ne soyez pas tentés - Moïse tard avertit l'
Israël - ne soyez pas tenté de dire à vous-mêmes (ce qui est en
Deutéronome 08:17), "Ma propre force et la puissance de
ma propre main ont remporté cette richesse pour moi », ou encore,
à-dire dans Deutéronome 09:04: «Le Seigneur nous a permis de
possession de ce pays à cause de nos vertus. "
Au contraire, il souligne,
c'est seulement parce que la méchanceté des Cananéens est
si grande que le Seigneur a à les chasser de ses terres,
et maintenant il est de vous donner une chance.
Mais il est conditionnel pour vous, tout comme il était pour eux.
Ne lui faites pas échouer ou il va vous chasser comme il chassa l'
Cananéens. C'est un thème dans le Deutéronome.
Nous allons voir dans un instant combien cela est important,
ou dans quelques conférences, l'importance de cette idée est pour
l'historien deutéronomiste en général.
Mais nous allons y arriver.
Un autre thème dans le livre du Deutéronome est le thème de
préoccupation providentiel, et qui apparaît dans le Deutéronome
8. Amour providentiel de Dieu et
soins pour Israël s'exprime à travers différentes métaphores dans l'
Bible. Et le prophète Osée,
qui semble avoir des liens très forts avec le livre de
Deutéronome, le prophète Osée se développer
encore cette image du parent et de l'enfant qui se produit dans le Deutéronome
8. D'une certaine manière,
la langue que nous étions seulement allusion à était vraiment l'
langue de mari et femme, vous le savez, quelqu'un qui simplement
aime quelqu'un, non pas parce qu'ils sont parfaits,
mais c'est leur choix.
Ils favorisent eux. Ils aiment la personne,
et ils font un lien avec eux.
Il n'implique rien sur d'autres personnes.
C'est simplement que la personne qui a fait l'objet.
Nous avons donc beaucoup de genre d'amour et de l'imagerie de mariage,
mari et femme imagerie, utilisé pour Dieu et Israël,
mais nous avons aussi cette mère et de l'enfant des images qui s'affiche.
Dans Deutéronome 32:10, l'image est celle d'un aigle
qui porte son jeune sur ses ailes:
Il le trouva dans une région désertique,
Dans une solitude aux effroyables hurlements vide.
Il lui engirded, veillait sur lui,
Lui gardé comme la prunelle de son œil.
Tel un aigle qui éveille ses oisillons,
Glissant le long de sa jeune, donc at-il étendit ses ailes et
l'emmener, lui rends long sur ses ailes;
Seul le Seigneur lui n'a guider ....
Il semble presque jouer sur l'idée que lorsque son enseignement
jeunes pour voler, l'aigle va les pousser hors de
le nid, coup sous eux, portent leur place pendant un certain temps sur
et encore jusqu'à ce qu'ils obtiennent l'idée.
Donc Dieu est à plusieurs reprises de tester et de corriger les Israélites
jusqu'à ce qu'ils soient prêts pour la Terre Promise.
Donc, le contenu du Deutéronome, qui sont ces adieux
discours et la mort et l'enterrement de Moïse,
sont une pierre angulaire de montage au récit du Pentateuque.
Mais dans le même temps, le Deutéronome fait vraiment pas
mettre un terme à ce récit, car à la fin de
Deutéronome, les promesses ne sont toujours pas remplies.
Les gens sont encore en dehors du terrain.
Certains ont suggéré que cela est tout à fait utile.
Il pointe vers une date exilique pour la composition finale de l'œuvre:
c'est-à-dire quand il a finalement été censuré,
les rédacteurs étaient en exil, écrit pour des gens qui vivent dans
exil. Et le Deuteronomist veut
qu'il soit clair que c'est la fidélité à la Torah,
plutôt que la résidence dans le pays qui est critique
importante. Mais en tout état de cause,
Deutéronome n'est pas simplement le livre de clôture de la
Pentateuque, ou l'histoire qui a commencé dans la Genèse;
c'est aussi la première partie d'un ensemble beaucoup plus vaste, plus littéraire
travailler, comme je l'ai dit la dernière fois, une œuvre qui se déroulera du
Deutéronome jusqu'à la fin des 2 Rois.
Et nous allons examiner aujourd'hui le programme et le travail
de cette soi-disant école deutéronomiste.
Mais avant cela, je voulais juste faire un peu
observations finales sur la théorie de la source et du Pentateuque.
Nous avons parlé de l'hypothèse du documentaire.
Nous avons parlé des différentes sources que les chercheurs
croient qu'ils ont pu identifier comme comprenant les cinq
livres du Pentateuque.
Et l'une des choses que j'ai mentionnées à quelques reprises sont
certains des débats qui ont lieu sur la question de la datation.
Il ya beaucoup de bagage idéologique qui est
impliqués dans la datation des sources.
Une des questions que je pense que c'est un vrai problème réside dans le fait
que la source sacerdotale, P, est si souvent mal jugé et
décrié. J'espère que le peu d'
le temps que nous avons passé sur les matériaux sacerdotales vous a donné quelques
appréciation de sa transformation de plus
Les rituels et les traditions israélites dans les pratiques symboliques qui
communiquerait convictions fondamentales sur la moralité,
convictions au sujet de la sainteté.
J'espère que cela vous a donné un sentiment de son éthique commune, par opposition à
une morale individuelle, l'idée que les actions de
chaque individu ont un impact sur la société dans son ensemble.
Mais l'anti-prêtre, le sentiment anti-culte,
du protestantisme européen, il ressort de l'histoire de
études bibliques au cours des derniers siècles.
Et il est évident en négatif de cette bourse
évaluation de la source sacerdotale de la Bible.
Donc, pour Wellhausen, la source sacerdotale,
qui met l'accent culte et le rituel - logiquement, il devait
représenter une étape dégénérer en retard dans l'évolution de
La religion israélite, car sacerdotale ritualiste
pratiques cultuelles, ce sont des dégénérescences.
Ce sont des mouvements loin de la vraie religion remplie de l'Esprit dans
son point de vue. Ainsi, selon Wellhausen,
la première période de l'ancien Israël doit avoir été
caractérisé par une forme libre et plus naturelle de la religion,
une relation intime avec Dieu, inutilisé ou sans tache
par les obsessions culte légalistes des prêtres et des cultes.
Il a fait valoir que, en 586, avec la destruction de
Jérusalem et les gens ont été pris en exil à Babylone,
c'est à ce moment, à Babylone, les prêtres étaient
en mesure de prendre le contrôle, et ils ont pu jouer sur
écrasante des sentiments de culpabilité et d'échec des exilés.
Les prêtres ont pu construire une nouvelle identité et
religion qui a souligné le péché du peuple,
et la nécessité de la pureté rituelle et observance rituelle et
légalisme que le dos de la route à Dieu.
Et ils ont pu se réécrire dans le
récits et les histoires du passé d'Israël.
Et cela, selon Wellhausen, était une dégénérescence.
Eh bien, cette reconstitution de l'évolution de Israélite
l'histoire, la religion israélite, excusez-moi, est vraiment tirée
plus de préjugés théologiques que c'est par historique
preuve. Et elle découle d'un évident
projection de la tension entre protestants et catholiques sur
Histoire israélite.
Il est également entraîné par un très sécessionniste du compte
Judaïsme comme étant quelque chose qui était déjà moribond au moment de
Jésus. Jésus vint, et relancé ce que
une religion remplie de l'Esprit nouveau, quand il avait pourri et
flétrie et dégénéré comme un arbre mort, comme Wellhausen se réfère
à elle. Cela ne veut pas dire que tous les
savants qui datent P pour la période post-exilique sont motivés
par les mêmes hypothèses problématiques.
Ce n'est certainement pas le cas.
Il ya des chercheurs de tous horizons et allégeances qui considèrent
P comme fin, et il ya quelques très bons
preuve objective pour la datation des pièces de P à la post-exilique
période, tout comme il est bon objectif
preuve des pièces datant de D et les autres sources pour le
période post-exilique.
Alors, quand il s'agit de dater les sources, certainement, je dirais
tous les spécialistes s'accordent à dire que les matériaux sacerdotales atteignent leur
forme définitive dans l'exil ou la période post-exilique.
Donc, c'est le sixième siècle, non?
(Vous allez le savoir, nous allons retourner à partir de
exil dans les années 530, ok?) Donc, quand nous parlons de
la période post-exilique, nous parlons de la période
après le retour.
Ainsi, la période de l'exil est le sixième siècle,
la majeure partie du milieu du VIe siècle.
Alors certes il a atteint sa forme définitive dans cette période,
de même que le Deutéronome, et le Pentateuque probablement
en général. Néanmoins,
il ya beaucoup de données qui suggèrent que la Priestly
sources conservent très tôt strates, tout comme D contient
pré-exilique ou matériau tôt.
P prône une éthique commune, et les prêtres post-exilique sont
va tourner de plus en plus à une éthique individuelle.
Plusieurs sections de P ne semblent pas jouer un sanctuaire central.
Rappelez-vous que l'idée du sanctuaire central a vraiment pris
tenir en 622, avec Josiah et la réforme de Josias.
Ainsi, il devient un véritable tournant pour nous dans des textes datant:
textes qui sont heureux avec l'existence de sanctuaires à travers
la terre d'Israël est probablement pré-Josiah, pré-622,
pré-exilique. Textes qui insistent sur une centrale
sanctuaire est probablement temps de Josias ou tard.
Et il ya de nombreuses sections de P qui ne semblent pas à assumer un
sanctuaire central.
Il ya des sections de P qui ne semblent assumer une centrale
sanctuaire. Plus important encore,
Je pense, P contient aucune interdiction universelle des mariages mixtes.
Il n'emploie pas ses lois de pureté ou de la langue pour marquer un
limite inséparable entre classes à l'intérieur d'Israël ou entre
Israélites et les Gentils autres.
L'utilisation de la pureté et de la langue de pureté d'inscrire frontières
entre Israël et les autres nations est très caractéristique de l'
période post-exilique.
Nous allons voir que lorsque nous y serons.
Il est donc très difficile de comprendre le silence de P dans cette
égard, si elle découle entièrement de la post-exilique,
cercles sacerdotaux.
Donc, je pense qu'au lieu de tracer une évolution ou une
dégénérescence - comme je l'ai sur le côté de la planche-un-
évolution ou une dégénérescence de JE,
la religion remplie de l'Esprit pur, à D,
la, religion éthique humanitaire,
P, obsession cultuelle et
culpabilisé légalisme, comme cela se fait ou implicites dans certaines
théorie de la source classique (certains, pas tous), il peut être préférable d'
voir ces trois comme représentant vraiment trois groupes distincts et
brins à peu près contemporains de l'ancienne tradition israélite
et l'expérience racontée par leurs propres perspectives.
Ces documents ont été transmis et développé par
différents milieux de la société israélite plus
siècles, et ils cristallisent à des moments différents.
JE a fragments qui sont assez vieux, mais il a probablement atteint son
forme définitive avant la centralisation du sanctuaire.
Il est toujours à l'aise avec l'existence de nombreux sacré
endroits à travers le pays, donc probablement avant 622.
Deutéronome contient les traditions nordiques d'avant la chute
d'Israël, qui était en 722, mais il a clairement été finalisée en
l'exil. Il ya beaucoup de passages qui
qu'il soit clair que c'est écrit dans une perspective exilique.
Et la source sacerdotale, de même, contient beaucoup,
de nombreuses traditions anciennes, mais atteint son plein et définitif
former dans la période exilique ou post-exilique.
Donc, chacun de ces sources complexes, multi-couches - dans chaque
l'un d'eux vous pouvez trouver différentes couches - chacune
possède ses propres accents, ses propres priorités,
ses propres perspectives.
Parfois, ils se complètent l'un l'autre.
Parfois, ils défient et se contredisent,
mais ils ne sont pas mieux considérés comme linéaire,
comme nous racontant une histoire linéaire ordonnée au sujet israélite
floraison de religion et à la décoloration.
Leur diversité n'a pas été aplaties ou homogénéisés par la
éditeur finale du texte.
Il a été préservée d'une façon qui stimule
réflexion et le débat.
Donc, avec ces conclusions, nous allons passer à autre chose
maintenant à la deuxième section importante de la Bible.
Nous avons discuté de la Torah ou Pentateuque,
et maintenant nous passons à la section de la Bible qui est
dénommés les Prophètes.
Cette section de la Bible est divisée en deux parties, nous renvoyons
les «anciens prophètes», puis les «prophètes».
Les anciens prophètes vont nous concerner pour les prochaines
conférences. Et les Prophètes antérieurs comprennent
les livres de Josué, des Juges, 1 et 2 Samuel,
1 et 2 Rois. Ils se lisent comme un historique
narrative. Ce matériau est un
compte théologiquement orientée de l'histoire d'Israël à partir de la
conquête de Canaan, ou ce qui est représenté comme l'
conquête de Canaan, à la destruction de l'Etat
par les Babyloniens en 587-586 avant notre ère.
Ce matériau est donc crucial de fond la lecture
les derniers prophètes.
Maintenant, les prophètes dernier est une collection de livres,
dont chacun porte le nom de la personne dont les prédictions
il est censé contenir.
Ces prophètes ont livré leurs oracles à des moments critiques dans
L'histoire d'Israël, dans l'histoire de la nation,
de sorte que leurs mots ne vont avoir du sens pour nous si nous avons d'abord
comprendre les crises historiques particulières qu'ils sont
adressage. Et ce récit historique
qui va de Josué à 2 Rois fournit cette information.
Il nous raconte les moments critiques de la nation
histoire, et qui nous aideront à fente puis les différents prophètes
po Donc les premiers prophètes,
ou les livres historiques, comme les livres de la Bible
que nous avons déjà étudié, contenir diverses sources âgées
qui ont été mis en place par une main plus tard.
Nous avons un éditeur ou un groupe de rédacteurs qui retravaillés ces anciens
sources. Ils ont des traditions orales.
Certains d'entre eux étaient probablement des archives royales et ainsi de suite.
Et ils tissent ensemble dans la forme que nous avons maintenant,
et c'est un processus qui est appelé rédaction ou
édition. La personne anonyme ou groupe
ou à l'école qui est responsable de la composition finale,
la rédaction finale de ces livres, mettrait les matériaux
ensemble par des versets insertion et des discours qui encadrent les
sources plus anciennes et les relier entre eux,
leur donner une sorte de fil de liaison commun.
Liaison et d'encadrement des passages et leurs rédacteurs de la
révisions des sources plus anciennes présentent certaines caractéristiques communes.
Ils harpe sur les mêmes thèmes, encore et encore;
ils utilisent une partie de la même langue, encore et encore;
ils partagent certaines hypothèses.
Et ces caractéristiques et hypothèses ont beaucoup en commun
avec le livre du Deutéronome, a beaucoup en commun avec le livre
du Deutéronome, et c'est ce qui a conduit l'allemand
savant, Martin Noth, à supposer que le Deutéronome et
ces livres historiques forment vraiment une unité,
de sorte que Deutéronome non seulement regarde en arrière et finit l'
Narratif du Pentateuque, il attend avec impatience que le
début de vraiment le récit historique qui est à
suivre. J, E et P semblent vraiment venir
à sa fin ici, il ya un débat sur
, mais parce que l'histoire d'interprétation qui fonctionne
de Joshua 2 Rois est basé sur des idéaux qui sont énoncées dans
le livre du Deutéronome, nous faisons référence à la personne ou l'
personnes qui expurgés cette unité tout comme le Deuteronomistic
historien, ou l'école deutéronomiste.
L'unité entière, dans son ensemble, a été censuré après
622: c'est clair.
Il assume et insiste sur la centralisation du culte.
Le dernier événement en date qui est mentionné dans 2 Rois est
quelque chose qui a eu lieu en 562.
C'est alors que le roi Joachin a été libéré de prison en
Babylone, en 562. Donc, le travail était probablement
conclu peu après cette date: si en exil ou vers l'
fin de la période exilique.
Martin Noth supposé qu'il y avait un éditeur.
D'autres chercheurs ont supposé qu'il y avait deux,
ou même plus, les éditions successives de ce
histoire, car il ya de multiples perspectives qui semblent
à représenter.
Mais la dernière semble être une perspective exilique,
le point de vue de quelqu'un assis en exil et nous serons
revenir à ce que dans un avenir conférence.
Certains des livres au sein de cette unité très grande,
ou au moins les traditions au sein de cette unité très grande,
sont moins influencés par le Deutéronome et ses thèmes et
ses préoccupations. Certains contiennent clairement
éléments et matériaux pré-dtr, si vous voulez.
Mais je vous encourage à lire l'excellente introduction à l'
Prophètes, la section de la Bible "Les prophètes", qui était
écrit par Marc Brettler dans votre étude de la Bible juive.
Je pense que c'est une excellente introduction à la complexité
de ce matériel.
Le trait le plus saillant de l'école deutéronomiste est l'
conviction que la résidence d'Israël dans la terre est un
fonction de son obéissance ou de désobéissance à l'alliance
avec Yahvé. Et cette conviction va
colorer sa présentation, son évaluation et sa
interprétation de l'histoire d'Israël et ses rois de
Joshua droite jusqu'à 2 Rois.
Yehezkel Kaufmann utilise le terme «historiosophie" que j'ai
écrit ici, historiosophie,
pour décrire ce matériau.
Si un historien pourrait simplement enregistrer les événements (comme si cela
une chose si simple à faire, mais on y va avec que pour un
moment) - un historien pourrait simplement enregistrer les événements,
Toutefois sélective ou partielle, pourrait essayer d'indiquer
cause et d'effet lorsque cela est possible, mais un historiosophie est un plus
philosophie consciente de l'histoire.
C'est en cherchant à déterminer le sens des événements pour attirer plus
philosophiques, idéologiques conclusions de
les événements de l'histoire, et à signaler à la plus grande
but ou de la conception de l'histoire, pour ne pas dire exactement ce qui s'est passé,
mais de dire pourquoi c'est arrivé et ce que cela signifie pour nous aujourd'hui que
c'est arrivé. Donc l'histoire deutéronomiste
n'est pas simplement une histoire d'Israël jusqu'à la destruction de
Jérusalem, c'est un historiosophie.
Il fait un argument et il est tentant de communiquer
le sens et la signification des événements de cette époque,
et il le fait à travers un motif, un motif littéraire nous
allons le voir, de récompense et de punition.
Il s'agit d'un point important, et que nous commençons à parcourir
le matériel, nous reviendrons à cela.
Nous reviendrons sur cette idée.
Il ya certaines caractéristiques clés de la pensée qui Deuteronomistic
ressortent de Joshua dans 2 Rois.
La première est la croyance en l'élection divine de Jérusalem.
Jérusalem est la ville que l'on appelle dans le Deutéronome quand
il dit que Dieu va choisir un lieu de provoquer son nom à habiter.
Dans les livres deutéronomistes, ce lieu va être
Jérusalem. Il ya aussi une croyance en l'
élection divine de David comme roi d'Israël et de sa dynastie.
Maintenant, c'est intéressant parce que les quatre autres livres de l'
Pentateuque ne mentionnent jamais un roi.
Dans la Genèse, à travers Numbers aucun des documents juridiques disent:
quand vous avez un roi c'est ce qu'il doit faire.
C'est seulement le livre du Deutéronome qui assume ou
se prépare pour une monarchie et contient la législation d'un roi,
et les choses qu'il doit faire.
Donc ce, encore une fois, souligne le lien
entre le Deutéronome et les livres suivants.
Deutéronome suppose un roi.
Il est en cours d'écriture et expurgés à un moment où il est
un roi en Israël, il ya eu des rois
Israël, et il fournit des lois pour
la construction d'une monarchie idéale.
Alors David, le thème de David comme roi élu de Dieu,
David aussi que le roi idéal, c'est autre chose qui est un
thème de ces livres.
Un autre thème que nous voyons dans ces livres ou caractéristique de l'
École Deuteronomistic est l'accent mis sur ce que nous appelons le
prophètes yahviste - prophètes comme Elie et Elisée.
Ces prophètes sont présentés comme des héros et champions de
la pureté religieuse.
Ils sont complètement contre toute forme de mélange de Yahweh
adorer avec d'autres éléments, tout type de syncrétisme.
L'autre chose que nous voyons dans le matériau Deuteronomistic est un
préférence pour Juda, le royaume du sud,
par rapport à une présentation très négatif de la
Nord-Uni, en Israël.
Le royaume du Nord d'Israël va venir pour très,
très mauvaise presse dans les mains des écrivains deutéronomistes,
ce qui montre qu'ils favorisent probablement ou proviennent de Juda.
Ainsi, les rois du nord vont être dénigré de manière uniforme.
Ils vont être dénigré parce qu'ils maintiennent cultes qui
rivaliser avec le sanctuaire central de Jérusalem.
Et cela va être ce que fait leur po
L'autre thème que nous voyons à travers le Deuteronomistic
matériau est la présentation négative des Cananéens.
Mais nous allons parler plus sur qui sont ces Cananéens étaient et comment
compliqué, en fait, que la présentation est.
Maintenant, les livres de Josué et des Juges qui ouvrent la
Histoire deutéronomiste, ces livres racontent ou se rapportent
l'histoire de la conquête du pays de Canaan par les Israélites
tribus, et les premières années de l'
règlement: c'est en juges.
Pour mieux comprendre certains des enjeux,
et l'émergence d'une structure tribale dans le pays,
il est utile de savoir quelque chose sur la géographie d'Israël,
c'est pourquoi je vous ai remis pour vous un couple de différentes
cartes, mais celui qui vous donne physique
caractéristiques (et qui est sur le dessus).
Il a souvent été souligné que dans les 4000 dernières années, plus
guerres ont été livrées pour la possession de la minuscule bande de
terre connue sous le nom de Canaan, ou la terre d'Israël,
ou en Palestine, que d'avoir été battus pour
presque toute autre région dans le monde.
Et dans le monde antique, la raison en est que
ce tout petit rectangle -, c'est environ 150 miles de long et 70
miles de large, environ de la taille de Rhode
Island - ce très petit rectangle se trouve sur le chemin de
partout la peine d'aller dans le Proche-Orient ancien.
Vous avez Egypte ici.
Vous avez Asie Mineure ici, et vous avez plus de Mésopotamie
ici. Pas une énorme quantité d'
valeur inhérente à cette bande de terre, mais il est important pour
où vous pourriez aller en voyageant à travers elle.
Donc, vous avez trois principales routes commerciales qui traversent le pays,
et ils ont été utilisés par les caravanes marchandes qui porterait or
et les céréales et les épices, textiles et autres marchandises entre
L'Egypte et le reste du Croissant Fertile et jusque dans
Asie Mineure. Donc, le contrôle de ces
routes internationales ont apporté beaucoup de richesse à l'
, mais l'emplacement central était un
épée à double tranchant, car en temps de paix, il
apporterait la prospérité, mais, bien sûr,
en temps de guerre, la terre était perpétuellement envahie comme des armées
serait sillonner la terre de partir à en découdre avec le grand
pouvoirs. Donc, sur le chemin de conquêtes
Egypte, ou Asie Mineure ou Mésopotamie, les armées seraient clochard
à travers le pays.
Et c'est ce qui explique la succession de dirigeants qui ont
lieu de la région: les Egyptiens,
les Amorites, les Israélites,
les Assyriens, les Babyloniens,
les Perses, les Grecs, les Grecs
Ptolémées, les Séleucides, les Romains, et la liste
continue que nous avançons dans la cité médiévale et les périodes modernes.
Or, malgré le fait qu'il s'agit d'un très petit morceau de terre,
il bénéficie d'une grande diversité géographique.
Donc, il ya trois principales subdivisions géographiques.
Vous pouvez les voir sur votre carte, et ils courent vraiment en bandes
du nord au sud.
Si vous regardez votre carte, vous verrez d'abord sur le côté ouest,
vous avez une basse plaine côtière.
Il est environ 20 ou 30 miles de large.
Il s'agit de la plaine côtière, et qui fournit,
ou qui est la route principale de l'Égypte ou en Égypte.
Cette zone était contrôlée par l'Egypte à l'époque présumée de
l'Exode. Du nord au sud,
à côté de cette plaine côtière, est une région de basses montagnes.
Ces montagnes basses sont coupées par des vallées qui courent sorte d'
est-ouest: vous verrez un là-bas, la vallée de Jezreel,
en particulier, qui a été particulièrement fertile
vallée. Ainsi, les vallées qui traversent
les montagnes sont extrêmement fertile.
La plaine de Megiddo se joint également à la vallée de Jezréel.
C'est la partie la plus fertile du pays,
mais il était aussi le lieu de nombreuses batailles les plus sanglantes
dans l'histoire d'Israël.
Ensuite, à côté de cette montagne central nord-sud,
vous avez aussi du nord au sud, ce que nous appelons le Grand
Jordan Rift Valley.
Il va de toute la longueur de tout le pays.
Et le Jourdain traverse cette vallée.
Il prend sa source dans la mer de Galilée ou lac de Tibériade, au nord,
et puis il s'écoule environ 65 miles, je crois,
jusqu'à la mer Morte.
À l'extrême nord de la vallée du Rift, est le mont Hermon,
qui est le point le plus haut.
Il est couvert de neige, le mont Hermon.
Et c'est le point le plus élevé en Israël, il s'élève environ 10.000
pieds au-dessus du niveau des mers.
La zone montagneuse centrale, ce sont entre 4000 et
10.000 pieds d'altitude.
Lorsque vous vous déplacez à partir de la zone centrale vers
Jérusalem - Jérusalem est d'environ 2500 pieds au dessus du niveau de la mer - mais
alors que vous continuez vers l'est vers la vallée du Rift,
cette zone est considérablement inférieur - et vous vous sentez comme vous voyagez
la route là-bas, la rapidité avec laquelle il tombe,
de sorte qu'au moment où vous arrivez à la mer de Galilée vous êtes 700
mètres sous le niveau de la mer, et la mer Morte est près de 1300
pieds au-dessous du niveau des mers.
C'est le point le plus bas de la surface émergée de la terre - si ce
chute spectaculaire en seulement une zone géographique très court.
Dans le nord, la rivière est entourée par de très
une végétation luxuriante sur les deux côtés, mais il n'ya pas de vie 65 miles
vers le sud par la Mer Morte.
C'est parce que l'eau est de 25% de sels et de minéraux - bien
J'ai entendu dire qu'ils ont trouvé une sorte de bactéries ou de quelque chose,
donc je suppose que je ne devrais pas plus dire qu'il n'y a pas d'
vie - mais essentiellement il n'ya pas de vie nous préoccuper dans
la région de la mer Morte.
C'est donc un secteur très désolé.
Et la tradition identifie comme le site de Sodome et
Gomorrhe. La zone autour de la mer est
essentiellement semi-désertique.
Nous appelons cela le désert, le désert de Judée entre
Jérusalem et la mer Morte, le désert de Juda ou
Judée. Donc, dans ce relativement petit
domaine, il est radicalement différentes régions, et ce fait a tenu
des implications importantes pour l'histoire d'Israël.
Unity a été difficile.
Étant un peu isolée, les habitants de chaque région
développé un caractère économique et culturel distinctif.
Vous avez le petit agriculteur installé dans la plus fertile
zones. Vous avez bergers semi-nomades.
Vous avez des citadins.
Vous avez marchands et les commerçants qui manipulent le commerce sur
les routes commerciales et bénéficiant contacts culturels plus larges.
Voilà donc la situation géographique de ce que nous sommes sur le point d'
lu dans le livre de Josué.
La structure de Josué est vraiment un peu simple.
Nous pouvons vraiment diviser en deux grandes parties.
Les 12 premiers chapitres forment une unité qui transmet l'invasion
et de conquête. Il ya certaine importance
éléments. Dans le chapitre 2, nous avons Joshua
envoyer des espions pour surveiller dehors du terrain.
Dans le chapitre 3, nous avons le récit de la traversée du Jourdain
River. Dans le chapitre 6, nous avons la bataille
de Jéricho. L'histoire de la bataille de
Jericho est vraiment un composite de deux comptes qui ont été
tissé ensemble dans un seul récit.
Ainsi, dans l'un d'eux les guerriers de Joshua semblent marcher silencieusement
autour de la ville sept fois.
Dans un autre, les prêtres portent l'arche autour de la ville 13
fois, de sorte que les chercheurs pensent qu'il ya deux comptes différents ici
tissés ensemble. Le chapitre 8 décrit la victoire
à un endroit appelé Aï, qui est près de Jéricho.
Chapitre 9 raconte l'histoire des Gabaonites qui se joignent à l'
Israélites, ils sont un groupe local qui
semble se joindre à eux.
Et puis 10 et 11 nous donne deux autres campagnes militaires.
Vers la fin de 11 ans, nous avons états de synthèse.
Dans Josué 10:40, nous lisons: «Et Josué vaincu
la terre entière, la montagne et la
Negeb "-, c'est le désert ici pour le sud -;» et le
plaine "- si vous avez la montagne,
les terres basses -; »et les pistes, et tous leurs rois;
il ne laissa échapper, mais il dévoua par interdit tout ce qui
respirait ". chapitre 11 souligne ensuite
que Josué a achevé la tâche qui avait été commencé par Moïse.
Au verset 15: «Tout comme le Seigneur l'avait ordonné
Son serviteur Moïse, Moïse avait chargé Joshua,
et ainsi de Josué, il ne négligea rien de tout
que l'Éternel avait commandé à Moïse ».
Et encore une fois, au verset 23, l'insistance:
"Ainsi Joshua a conquis l'ensemble du pays,
tout comme le Seigneur avait promis à Moïse;
et Joshua attribué à Israël à partager selon
leurs divisions tribales, et le pays fut en repos
guerre. "Donc les chapitres 13 et 21 vont à
décrire la division de la terre entre les tribus et puis
nous avons une sorte de rangement à la fin.
Les autres chapitres sont des appendices: 23 est un adieu
adresse, et le 24 est un renouvellement de l'alliance à Sichem,
qui apporte tout à une belle conclusion.
Ainsi le récit dans la première partie de Josué,
Joshua 2 à 12, décrit l'invasion
Israélites comme une confédération organisée des 12 tribus dont
conquête est accomplie en quelques batailles décisives dans le cadre du
leadership militaire de Josué.
Et les Cananéens désunis mis en place peu ou pas de résistance:
ils sont paralysés par la peur qui est envoyé par Dieu.
Tous ceux qui ont été conquis sont mis à l'interdiction ou la
herem - c'est le dévouement sacré des objets et des personnes
à Dieu, ce qui a entraîné leur mort,
de sorte qu'ils ont été totalement détruits.
Ainsi, la première moitié du livre de Josué contient une
rationalisé compte, idéalisée selon laquelle l'
Israël gérés dans une période relativement courte à prendre
la région montagneuse centrale, confinant les Philistins à un
petite bande ici, sur la plaine côtière.
Nous viendrons à les Philistins dans une minute.
Le récit de la conquête de Josué 2 à 12,
est concerné à exprimer l'idée de base que d'Israël
victoires n'auraient pas été possibles sans l'Éternel,
sans son aide merveilleuse.
C'était l'Eternel, qui a divisé la Jordanie devant eux.
Il était Yahvé qui démolit les murs de Jéricho.
Il était Yahvé qui a mis la peur dans les cœurs des Cananéens.
Yahvé était présent à chaque bataille.
L'arche était un signe visible de sa présence et il marcha
devant eux. Et peu de temps après la conquête
représentants de toutes les tribus d'Israël vont
rencontrer et faire un engagement solennel à Sichem pour être le peuple de
Yahvé, pour l'adorer seul.
Et d'après le livre de Josué, tribal d'Israël
la structure a pris sa forme classique à cette époque.
C'est une image très soignée de la conquête rapide du pays de Canaan,
mais c'est en contradiction avec les déclarations ailleurs dans Joshua
et dans le livre des Juges.
Par exemple, les victoires dans les chapitres 2
à 10 sont confinés dans une zone très petite,
ce serait en fait la tribu de Benjamin fondamentalement,
si juste une petite zone.
Dans Josué 13:01: Joshua 13 s'ouvre avec l'
déclaration que Josué était vieux, avancé en âge,
et il y avait beaucoup de terres restant à être possédé.
Dans Josué 10 (qui est dans la première partie de Joshua - Joshua 10)
versets 36-39 signalent la conquête de plusieurs villes dans le sud,
y compris Hébron et Débir.
Mais dans les Juges, nous lisons que s'ils n'avaient pas été
capturés: ils ont été capturés plus tard, après la mort de Josué.
Joshua 12:10 rapporte la défaite du roi de Jérusalem.
Dans Juges 1:08 et 21, nous lisons que les gens de
Juda fit ce (conquis le roi de Jérusalem), et que
En dépit de cette victoire, ils n'ont pas réellement chasser le
habitants, les Jébuséens qui habitaient là.
Et il n'est pas jusqu'à ce que le roi David, 200 ans plus tard que,
En fait, nous allons en savoir plus sur la prise de Jérusalem.
Les juges 1 donne une longue liste des endroits à partir de laquelle le
Cananéens n'ont pas été expulsés.
Également des preuves archéologiques contredit l'image dans
Joshua. Au Proche-Orient ancien,
villes détruites avaient tendance à être stabilisée, puis une nouvelle ville
serait tout simplement être construit sur les ruines,
et vous auriez ces monticules hausse lentement - chacun de ceux
est appelé un dire (si vous avez entendu parler de Tell Dor?).
Ce sont des monticules qui représentent les couches successives
d'détruit et reconstruit les villes.
Et fouilles révéleront les couches de destruction sous la
étage de nouvelles villes.
Donc, après le récit biblique, on s'attendrait
preuve d'une destruction du XIIIe siècle des villes cananéennes.
Et les archéologues depuis longtemps étaient convaincus qu'ils
trouveraient ces couches de destruction.
Mais ils ont été déçus.
Ils ont trouvé vraiment aucune preuve d'une vaste conquête
et la destruction en treizième et douzième siècle
couches archéologiques.
Certains des sites que l'on dit être détruite par Josué et
les Israélites n'étaient même pas occupés à cette période,
l'âge du bronze tardif, au début de l'âge du fer;
l'âge du fer commence autour de 1200.
Fouilles à Jéricho et à Aï indiquent que ces deux
villes ont été dévastées au moins 200 ans avant la probable
temps de Josué, il n'y avait même pas de murs
à Jéricho à l'époque de Josué.
De 20 sites identifiables qui ont été dites à conquérir ou
capturé par Josué et les générations à venir,
seulement deux couches de destruction de montrer pour le moment,
Hazor et Béthel.
Et pourtant, curieusement, la capture de Hazor décrit dans
Joshua est contredite ailleurs dans la Bible,
parce que dans les Juges 4 et 5, il est encore une ville cananéenne.
Il y est dit que c'est encore une ville cananéenne et
Joshua n'a pas réussi à le prendre.
Donc, la conclusion qu'on peut tirer de tout cela est que Joshua
2 à 12 est une sorte de construction idéologique,
la signification et le but que nous viendrons
sauvegarder dans un instant.
Mais de toute évidence la formation de l'État-nation,
Israël, était beaucoup plus compliquée que l'image
qui est présenté dans Josué 2 à 12.
Les chercheurs ont proposé trois modèles possibles pour expliquer l'
formation d'Israël.
Le premier est un modèle d'immigration.
Cela a été posée la première fois par des chercheurs allemands.
Depuis les principales villes cananéennes qui existaient dans le pays à ce
le temps était fortifié ou villes fortifiées bas dans les plaines,
les Israélites, il est pensé en fonction de cette
modèle, serait entré et ils auraient occupé le
très peu peuplée hautes terres centrales.
Ils ont commencé lentement à prendre le contrôle des plaines
qui descend des montagnes.
Eh bien, nous savons qu'à la fin de l'âge du bronze tardif,
au début de l'âge du fer, vers 1200,
ce fut une période de grands bouleversements dans toute la
Monde méditerranéen.
Nous avons l'effondrement de la civilisation mycénienne.
Nous avons les guerres de Troie.
Les Hittites ont envahi l'Asie Mineure, la Turquie moderne à l'
nord. Et ces bouleversements sont en tête
des migrations massives, les migrations de personnes.
Nombreux sont ceux qui naviguent de la Grèce continentale et du grec
Îles, et ils inondent ce domaine,
les côtes de la Phénicie, les côtes de Canaan et l'Egypte.
Et ces gens sont parlé à beaucoup de nos anciens
sources. Ils sont considérés comme des
«Peuples de la mer», venant de la mer,
des îles et des zones côtières du nord-est
Méditerranée. L'un de ces peuples de la
mer, l'un de ces groupes, une zone habitée ici:
Perasta ou Pelasta.
Le mot «Palestine» vient de cela, Peresta,
Palesta ou Philistins.
Il est tout de même racine.
Et si un groupe si ces peuples mer arrive et occupe
ce domaine. Ils seront les Philistins,
la région qui est maintenant la bande de Gaza.
Et ils ont trouvé les cinq villes des Philistins que vous
entendre parler de plus en plus dans le livre des Juges:
Gaza, Ashkelon, Gath, Ashdod et Ekron.
L'idée du modèle de l'immigration est que le règlement hébreu
aurait probablement eu lieu à peu près au même moment dans la
dernière partie du treizième siècle.
Les Hébreux pourrait profiter de l'ensemble de ces
bouleversements et affaibli l'emprise de l'Egypte.
Rappelez-Egypte avait le contrôle de cette région, mais leur portée était
affaiblissant avec le flot de personnes venant de la mer
et d'autres migrations.
Leur attente a été s'affaiblit et les Hébreux aurait pu
de profiter de cela et entrer dans et occuper des zones dans le
hauts plateaux du centre.
Le problème avec le modèle de l'immigration,
encore une fois, c'est le dossier archéologique.
Les archéologues ont, en effet, trouvé plusieurs sites
la région montagneuse centrale - ce qui est assez passionnant - et
ils ont été clairement nouvellement établis dans le treizième,
douzième, onzième siècles.
Il apparaît donc clairement quelque chose de nouveau qui se passait dans la centrale
hautes terres pour le moment.
Elles s'étendent dans tout le pays, mais surtout le central
Highlands. Et ceux-ci sont considérés comme
Israélite, en particulier parce qu'ils apparaissent dans les endroits que l'
Bible identifie comme des bastions d'Israël.
Rappelez-vous aussi, vous avez la stèle de Merenptah
1204, dans laquelle le pharaon égyptien se vante d'avoir réussi
d'anéantir Israël.
Il est évidemment un motif d'orgueil hyperbolique, mais le fait est qu'il montre
qu'il y avait une entité identifiable, Israël en Canaan,
en 1204. Ces nouveaux XIIIe siècle
colonies, cependant, sont dans leur culture matérielle,
c'est-à-dire leurs pots et leurs pots et leurs maisons,
entièrement cananéenne.
Les habitants semblent avoir été des paysans,
comme les autres Cananéens.
Une différence intéressante est l'absence d'os de porc,
ce qui est assez intéressant.
Mais en tout cas, ce qui suggère que ces
colonies ont été établies pacifiquement, non pas par un groupe
entrant et conquérante.
Peut-être qu'ils ont émergé de l'intérieur, plutôt que d'être mis en place
par les peuples qui immigrent au dehors.
Donc, il ya deux autres modèles, puis, différents modèles de la
modèle immigration, deux autres modèles pour
comprendre la formation d'Israël, qui s'appuient sur cette
preuves archéologiques.
Le second modèle est ce que nous appelons le modèle de révolte.
Le modèle de révolte propose qu'Israël a commencé vraiment comme un bien social
révolution au sein de Canaan.
Nous avons un ensemble de lettres.
Ce sont des lettres qui datent du siècle BCE quatorzième.
Ils ont été écrits par des gens de Canaan au pharaon dans
Egypte - rappelez-vous le Pharaon a encore le contrôle de Canaan à
cette fois. Et dans ces lettres, il ya
beaucoup de plaintes au sujet des groupes qui sont à l'origine de troubles et
bouleversé en Canaan. Ils contestent l'Egypte
gouverner. Et ces personnes sont appelées
Habiru ou Abiru.
Ils n'étaient pas un groupe ethnique tellement comme un marginal sociale
groupe de personnes dans la révolte, si vous voulez.
Certains ont suggéré que Israélites sortir d'Egypte
peut se sont joints à ces Cananéens mécontents dans
révolte, connu sous le nom Habiru,
ces fauteurs de troubles, d'établir leurs propres
colonies et d'adorer un Dieu libérateur,
Yahvé, plutôt que de suivre la règle de Pharaon.
Un modèle final, alors, est un modèle de progressive
émergence, qui détient simplement que Israélites étaient essentiellement
Cananéens qui avaient développé une identité distincte et se sont installés
de plus en plus dans les hautes terres centrales.
Ils se sont retirés et se sont installés dans cette zone.
La théorie ne cherche pas à expliquer pourquoi ils se sont séparés.
Nous ne savons pas. C'était peut-être la désaffection.
Ils ont peut-être poussé par les peuples de la mer envahissant.
Et c'était peut-être autre chose.
Mais ils se sont retirés pour quelque raison.
Et comment et pourquoi ils ont pris le culte de Yahvé ou l'
culte de Yahvé n'est pas vraiment clair;
mais il semble avoir été ce qui a marqué en tant que distincte de
autres Cananéens.
Le culte de Yahvé peut avoir été introduit par des personnes qui fuient
l'esclavage d'Egypte.
La plupart des spécialistes voient l'histoire de l'Exode comme une preuve de l'
présence de certains esclaves fugitifs au sein de cette communauté.
Donc, la chose importante est que les Hébreux à ce stade étaient
probablement pas un peuple uni.
Divers éléments sont entrés dans le mix final qui émergerait comme
la nation d'Israël: Cananéens locales qui,
pour une raison quelconque, se retira et établi leur
propres colonies, avec un matériau continu
culture, et établi agricole
mode de vie - vous les avez.
Vous avez esclaves en fuite de l'Égypte.
Et rappelez-vous, nous avons des preuves de
destruction de l'extérieur, donc il aurait également pu être
certains étrangers qui entrent et détruire et de décantation.
Il semble même que certains étrangers locales ont été admis à l'
communauté. Nous lisons des Madianites qui
alliance dans la communauté.
Nous lisons Kénites qui alliance dans la communauté.
Et archéologie soutient cette image de la fusion des peuples,
une image de la fusion des peuples,
plutôt que la conquête ou même à grande échelle immigration,
parce que les nouveaux établissements dans cette période montrent une telle continuité
avec le passé, et non pas une rupture totale,
pas le début de quelque chose de radicalement nouveau.
Et, de plus, une partie des éléments de ce groupe peut
ont apporté avec eux l'histoire d'une évasion miraculeuse de
Egypte. Ils ont peut-être compris
être l'œuvre de l'Éternel, un dieu connu probablement de
régions du sud.
Et si le groupe mixte qui s'unissent pour devenir
Israël a accepté Yahvé, mais peut-être pas exclusivement,
et a adopté l'histoire nationale de l'Exode comme sa propre à certains
Point. Les tribus hébraïques,
eux-mêmes, étaient probablement encore dans le processus de formation.
Mais la structure tribale de la société israélite qui serait
développer serait renforcée par la division naturelle du terrain
dans ces zones géographiques distinctes: que seul renforcé le
tribalisation de la société.
Et ces tribus locales n'ont probablement assimiler les éléments de la
population locale.
Nous avons vraiment vu déjà la composition ethnique des divers éléments
reflété dans l'imagerie et les institutions religieuses.
Nous avons vu que l'Eternel est représenté dans des termes qui rappellent
de l'habitant de la tente, El, le dieu de la semi-nomade
tente-logement Hébreux et leurs patriarches,
et certainement un dieu du panthéon cananéen.
Nous avons vu que Yahweh est aussi représenté en termes
rappelle Baal du panthéon cananéen,
le Dieu de la population cananéenne réglées.
En fait, dans le livre des Juges, vous pourrez le lire d'un temple à
Dieu d'Israël, le Dieu de l'Alliance,
et ce temple est appelé le Temple du Dieu de l'
Pacte ou Baal Berit.
Le mot "Berit" signifie alliance.
Il est appelé Baal Berit, il est appelé comme El Berit ou
Baal El Berit, et c'est en référence à
Yahweh. Ces termes sont tous utilisés pour
décrire le Dieu de l'Alliance.
Donc en bref, nous pouvons faire l'hypothèse vraiment un
union d'éléments culturels, religieux et ethniques:
agriculteurs cananéens locales, semi-nomades Hébreux peut-être,
de l'Exode, esclaves en fuite,
peut-être Habiru / Abiru, un groupe mécontent qui est en
révolte. Tous ces éléments viendraient
ensemble pour produire ce qui serait une nouvelle politique et religieuse
réalité appelée Israël.
Si c'est le cas, pourquoi le livre de Josué fournir un tel différent
compte, une conquête à l'extérieur au moyen d'une guerre menée par l'
armées du Seigneur?
Parce que dans ce compte compétence militaire est beaucoup moins
importante que la préparation du rituel et de la pureté.
Les Israélites mars autour de Jéricho pendant six jours avec sept
prêtres portant sept cornes et l'arche de l'alliance,
puis avec un souffle et un cri la tête-bêche des parois.
La conquête est représentée comme une victoire miraculeuse de Dieu.
Cela a souligné dans Josué 24:12.
Il était Dieu, et non l'épée ou l'arc, qui chassa l'
ennemi. Et pourquoi la demande de l'absolu
destruction des Cananéens lorsque les points de preuve pour fermer
Origines cananéennes?
Cette pratique, dont j'ai déjà parlé et c'est
connu comme herem ou l'interdiction, n'est pas propre à Israël.
Je sais que certains d'entre vous ont étudié dans les sections:
vous avez regardé l'inscription du roi Mesha,
Le roi Mesha de Moab.
Il est très important, célèbre inscription de l'
IXe siècle avant notre ère, écrit par le roi Mesha de Moab
Moab est au sud-est de la mer Morte,
Le roi Mesha de Moab.
Et dans l'inscription, écrit-il, il se vante:
«Et le dieu Chemosh m'a dit, allez, prenez Nebo d'Israël.
Je suis donc allé par nuit et combattu contre elle de la rupture de
aube jusqu'à midi, prendre et tuer tous 7000
les hommes, les garçons, les femmes et les filles et la servante
serviteurs, car j'avais consacré à la destruction du dieu
Ashtar Chemosh ", se référant à herem.
Il est probable que de telles allégations sont hyperboliques à Moab,
et il est probable qu'ils étaient hyperbolique en Israël.
Mais cela n'enlève rien à la valeur de choc pour un lecteur moderne,
même si la guerre à notre époque n'est pas moins sauvage et pas moins
brutal. Mais la question importante ici
C'est pourquoi un écrivain biblique ou éditeur voudraient insister pour que
les Cananéens devaient être complètement détruites.
Je pense assertions d'identité et de l'indépendance nationale sont
souvent fondée sur la différenciation des autres.
Si les Israélites étaient, en fait, fondamentalement Cananéen,
qui s'était retiré de la plus grande collective,
qui a insisté sur la suzeraineté de l'Éternel,
puis Cananéens qui n'ont pas les rejoindre dans cette étaient un spécial
menace pour la nouvelle Yahwism.
Cette même dynamique de rivalité fraternelle intense apparaît à nouveau dans
les premiers siècles de l'ère commune,
lorsque certains juifs séparés des autres et dans la différenciation
eux-mêmes et de créer leur propre identité en tant que chrétiens,
ressenti le besoin de s'engager dans terriblement injurieux et
rhétorique violente contre leurs coreligionnaires.
Ce qui est intéressant, cependant, est que nous ne devons pas
ignorer une autre voix qui est dans le texte biblique,
et c'est une voix qui ajoute un niveau de complexité à cette
image. Parce que le long de la idéalisée
représentation de la conquête israélite dans la première moitié du
le livre de Josué, aux côtés de l'appel à la
destruction de tous les Cananéens, on trouve des histoires intéressantes
alliances et l'intégration des différents groupes cananéennes.
En effet, qui fut l'un des héroïnes de la Bataille d'
Jericho, si elle n'est pas une femme cananéenne, une prostituée ni moins,
nommée Rahab. Elle déclare sa foi en
Yahvé et elle livre la ville aux mains de Josué.
L'auteur biblique a jugé bon de préserver et de comprendre ce
compte d'une prostituée cananéenne héroïque.
Un autre groupe Cananéens, les Gabaonites
tromper les Israélites en faisant une alliance avec eux,
et c'est une alliance d'Israël se sentent alors lié à
observer. Michael Coogan a décrit
ces histoires que les contes étiologiques.
Ce sont des tentatives pour expliquer le fait qu'il ya beaucoup de
Groupes cananéens compris en Israël;
et nous avons besoin de comprendre et d'expliquer cette réalité autant que
nous vous transmettons un compte idéologique dans lequel tous les Cananéens
sont effacés ou détruits.
À tout le moins, ces histoires soulèvent des questions
sur le portrait biblique ou représentation de l'invasion et
conquête. Et tout au plus,
ils illustrent le goût des écrivains bibliques pour littéraire
subversion encore une fois, quelque chose que nous verrons plus et
plus. L'impératif de préserver un
identité distincte - sur la base d'abandonner le culte des autres
dieux ou des dieux anciens et d'observer tout ce qui est écrit dans la loi
de Moïse - est réitéré dans le discours d'adieu de Josué
Josué 23, et dans le renouvellement de l'alliance
cérémonie à 24. Et l'idée centrale est que
il ya une réponse appropriée aux actes puissants de Dieu au nom de
Israël, et c'est le respect résolue
du livre de la Torah de Moïse, sans brassage
avec les peuples qui restent.
Ainsi, dans Josué 23:7-8: "Ne pas prononcer les noms des
leurs dieux ou jurent que par eux, ne leur servent pas ou se prosternent
pour eux, mais retenez le Seigneur votre Dieu comme vous l'avez fait
ce jour »Et les versets 11 à 13.:
Pour vous-mêmes, par conséquent, être plus attentifs à
aimeras le Seigneur ton Dieu.
Pour devriez vous tourner le dos et attachez-vous au reste
de ces pays - à ceux qui sont parmi vous - et
marier avec eux, et ils vous rejoindre
vous joindre, savoir avec certitude que le Seigneur ton Dieu, ne sera pas
continuer à conduire ces nations devant vous;
ils sont devenus un piège et un piège pour vous,
un fléau à vos côtés et des épines dans vos yeux,
jusqu'à ce que vous ayez péri de dessus ce bon pays que l'Éternel, ton Dieu,
vous donné. En 24, les Israélites sont
assemblé à Sichem pour renouveler l'alliance,
et Josué raconte hauts faits de Dieu en faveur d'Israël
et les exhorte à choisir qui ils vont servir:
Yahvé qui a fait tout cela pour
eux si injustement, ou les dieux de ceux dont
terres qu'ils s'installent po
Et les gens sont avertis de la jalousie de Dieu.
Il exige loyauté exclusive.
Il ne tolérera aucun écart dans le service de
dieux étrangers. L'interdiction des mariages ici
est tout à fait spécifique.
Elle est dirigée contre les Cananéens seulement,
tous les non-Israélites, pour une raison très précise:
la pureté religieuse.
Mariage avec Cananéens, les personnes les plus proches de vous,
spécifiquement, conduira à l'adoration de
dieu, et Israël de l'époux est de montrer indivise
fidélité à Dieu, ou que Dieu aura le don de
la terre d'elle comme il l'a fait les Cananéens.
Une dernière remarque pour vous de penser.
Examinons la situation des Israélites dans le sixième siècle,
moment de la rédaction finale de l'histoire deutéronomiste.
Les Israélites sont assis en exil à Babylone.
Ils essaient de donner un sens à la tragédie qui s'est abattue sur
eux, la perte de leurs terres.
Voyez comment un texte comme Joshua Joshua 23 et 24 serait aller un long
expliquent en partie leur sort tout en conservant la foi en
Yahweh. Nous allons revenir à ce
quand nous arrivons à la conclusion de l'histoire deutéronomiste à 2
Kings.